tout cela était bientôt terminé figa en
live bonjour nous sommes en direct ce
jeudi pour une question science une
question santé qu'on ne se pose et qu'on
aimerait se poser depuis à peu près 3
ans on va se demander si c'est la fin ou
non du covid et pour parler de ce sujet
là je suis avec Vincent bonheur bonjour
Vincent bonjour Vincent science au
Figaro spécialiste de ces de ces
questions Vincent pourquoi est-ce que ça
sent bon pour la fin du covid
c'est la lecture des indicateurs
habituels qui sont à la fois les
contaminations donc le nombre de cas
quotidiens mais aussi les indicateurs un
peu plus de plus long terme qui sont les
formes graves donc les amis sur
l'hôpital les admissions en réanimation
ou même les décès qui qui sont quand
même tous dans le vert c'est à dire que
on a une baisse continuelle de tous ces
indicateurs depuis plus d'un mois
maintenant
et on arrive surtout à des niveaux
exceptionnellement basse c'est-à-dire
qu'on a à la fois en termes d'incidence
donc le nombre de personnes qui qui sont
contaminés chaque jour des niveaux qui
précèdent la période au micro-ondes je
rappelle là que le variant au
micro-ondes a bousculé l'épidémie parce
qu'il était beaucoup plus contagieux on
est passé du norme à 10000 cas par jour
à des pics à 60 000 100000 200000 même à
certains moments là pardon là on retombe
sous les 5000 cas par jour ce qui n'est
ce qui est inédit depuis octobre
2021 donc ce qui nous ce qui fait quand
même un certain temps et c'est pareil et
c'est là que c'est très rassurant sur
les hospitalisations sur les formes
graves on a environ une trentaine de
personnes qui sont admises chaque jour
dans un système dans un service de soins
intensifs et là pareil on a pas vu un
nombre aussi bas depuis depuis
maintenant un an et demi voir deux ans
donc on est on est dans une situation
extrêmement confortable alors j'invite à
nous poser leurs questions on essayait
d'y répondre comme d'habitude du mieux
qu'on peut cet article que vous pourrez
trouver sur le site du Figaro que vous
avez écrit l'année 23 marquera-t-il la
fin l'épidémie de covid en France un
article qui a retrouvé dans le Journal
du jour et on voit cette courbe et on
voit que ce que je vous dis tout à
l'heure on est tout en bas de cette
vague et en plus de ça on est quand même
un moment fin janvier ou les épidémies
normalement oui alors c'est pas la
première fois que j'ai l'impression de
venir sur plateau la fin du covid mais
c'est très compliqué de caractériser la
fin du d'une épidémie d'une pandémie
autant le début est facile à voir autant
autant la fin c'est compliqué à le
signaler il y a en fait il y a eu
plusieurs fins il y a eu le premier la
première fin quand on est sorti de
l'urgence ou on a été surpris par le par
le virus on a été obligé de confiner le
pays de prendre des mesures drastiques
d'éloignement avec d'abord le
confinement les couvre-feu puis les
passes sanitaires etc ça fait quand même
un an maintenant qu'on est sorti de
cette logique là qu'on vit avec le virus
mais le virus continue à circuler on le
voit d'ailleurs sur le graphique avec ce
phénomène de vague successives et là ce
qui se passe et c'est la première fois
je crois qu'on l'observe c'est que
le nombre de Cannes ne sont pas décidés
à remonter alors peut-être que ce sera
le cas dans les dans les prochains jours
prochaines semaines mais on aurait pu
attendre une reprise des contaminations
avec la rentrée du mois de janvier c'est
à dire que que l'incidence baisse avec
les vacances c'était quelque chose de
prévisible qu'on pouvait espérer malgré
le côté réveillon familial des défaites
de Noël on sait que quand les écoles
sont fermées quand les entreprises sont
moins remplies quand il y a moins de
monde dans les transports il y a moins
d'endroits où on se contamine donc on
pouvait s'attendre quand même à une
espèce de cassure et donc une baisse de
contamination des formes graves avec ses
vacances mais dans ces cas là on
s'attendait aussi logiquement à une
autre prise en janvier et vivre comme ça
avec cette ce rythme un peu sinusoïdal
et des piques et des et des creux de
vagues de manière totalement acceptable
pour notre système de soins et la baisse
a continué c'est là que c'est plutôt
surprenant mais surtout que c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle on continue alors que
il fait froid alors que on vit de envie
dedans dans des milieux confinés on voit
pour les Parisiens qui prennent le métro
les gens qui portent le masque ont quand
même pas majoritaire les gestes
barrières n'existent quasiment plus
personne n'est respecte je crois que
c'est ça fait partie du des souvenirs du
moment où on se faisait pas la bise et
on se serrait pas la main en tout cas
dans les cadres
non institutionnel c'est ces gestes là
font sont redevenus normaux et pour
autant l'épidémie continue à reculer
donc ça c'est quand même la bonne
nouvelle de cette rentrée on avait le
place du Kindy mais même il faut
continuer les mesures sanitaires lorsque
nous voyons les gastro toujours manque
d'hygiène effectivement tout toutes ces
bonnes pratiques qu'on a appris servent
pour les autres épidémies exactement
pareil la gastro parce que bon il y a
des galéries de virus hivernaux qui qui
circulent on a beaucoup parlé de la
bronchiolite et de la grippe qui sont
aussi sur une phase de reflux autant la
bronchiolite on a on a eu un pic
historiquement au j'ai fait une épidémie
un peu plus précoce que d'habitude
et autant l'épidémie semble
véritablement derrière nous c'est ça
paraît très peu probable parce que les
différentes sous du virus ont circulés
assez largement que que l'épidémie
repartent pour le coup pour pour la
grippe il y a encore un point
d'interrogation parce qu'on a eu une
épidémie précoce pas si élevée que ça
quand on compare avec les autres années
un peu plus tôt on est sur une phase de
reflux mais comme on est encore très tôt
dans l'hiver et que il y a surtout une
souche du virus qui a circulé il n'est
pas exclu que le virus reprenne dans les
prochaines semaines dans les prochains
mois donc là là moi on n'en sait rien
c'est c'est une possibilité je j'insiste
dessus donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a
quand même un intérêt de continuer à se
protéger à faire attention et on parlait
de la de la gastro et on voit quand même
un signal au niveau du du de virus de
type gastro-entérite qui commence à à
progresser et là on est dans cette
géographie habituelle en fait des virus
c'est ça qui est intéressant qui va
falloir réussir à comprendre pour les
années à venir c'est comment est-ce que
le sarce coffre 2 donc le virus des est
responsable du covid va s'inscrire dans
cette géographie à quel moment est-ce
que les vagues vont pouvoir se
superposer on a vu avec la grippe que la
grippe a chassé le VRS en quelque sorte
donc comment ça va comment ce sera le
cas à l'avenir on verra bien et juste un
dernier point les les la gastro-entérite
n'a pas le même mode de contamination
c'est c'est une contamination orale
aéroportée donc là le lavage de mains
les gels hydroalcooliques sont hyper
important face à ces maladies quand ils
le sont moins pour le covid ou c'est
vraiment l'aération le port du masque
qui sont les meilleurs outils pour s'en
protéger on valide toujours qui nous dit
peut-être le résultat des vaccinations
oui exactement la vaccination qui a bien
aidé qui maintenant alors d'ailleurs la
question qui continue pour une certaine
partie de la population oui alors
il y a plusieurs choses à dire là dessus
on va voir il faut regarder les choses
dans une certaine temporalité qu'une
épidémie se termine et qu'une pandémie
se termine c'est normal
on ça
encore heureux sinon l'unité
n'existerait plus donc on l'a vu avec la
grippe espagnole au début du siècle avec
les grippes asiatiques du milieu de
siècle mais tous les pandémies on se
rythme de vie de deux trois ans avec
cette même phase une phase aiguë une
phase d'habitude une phase d'habitude
mais avec une mortalité qui reste élevée
rappelons qu'en 2022 pour le covid a
quand même eu 40 40000 morts et puis
après cette normalisation du virus qui
s'inscrit donc dans dans le paysage
habituel ce qui a permis la vaccination
c'est pas tant d'accélérer ce rythme
mais c'est que c'est d'adoucir en fait
les conséquences c'est que on se voit
que sinon on s'est protégé et on a pas
de temps gagné du temps que ça mais on a
gagné des vies c'est-à-dire que
l'immunité donc ce qui nous protège face
à l'infection de virus à progressé ma
population sans cela nous coûte en vie
humaine parce que pour s'y iPad la
vaccination le immunitaire aurait
coûté un certain nombre de vie tous les
gens qui auraient été contaminés qui ont
serré morts donc cette vaccination nous
a permis gagner un nombre nous a permis
de gagner des vies et il nous a permis
de d'affronter donc ce deuxième temps de
la pandémie de manière beaucoup plus
sereine et d'arriver aujourd'hui dans
une situation très confortable qui plus
est avec les nouveaux variants parce que
comme on a été vacciné pour la plupart
d'entre nous on estime à 90 95% je crois
que la population qui a au moins une
dose de vaccins et qu'en plus on a été
recontacté derrière notre organisme est
habitué à ce virus sous ces différentes
formes la force originale contre
laquelle était vaccinée et les formes
des variants qui qui ont circulé et qui
permet de donc de protéger contre les
femmes graves mais aussi de limiter les
transmissions ce qu'on a beaucoup dit
qu'il est vaccins étaient moins
efficaces sur les transmissions ça ne
veut pas dire qu'ils ne sont plus
efficaces et j'insiste dessus et c'est
peut-être une heure que nous on a fait
journalistiquement aussi c'est pas parce
qu'on est passé de 90 à 60 ou 50%
d'efficacité quand on est passé une
efficacité qui est nul les vaccins
contribue à freiner la circulation du
virus même s'il ne sera pas il ne sera
pas totalement alors voyons ça va me
permettre de parler là on parle de la
situation en France est-ce que
mondialement on peut dire que la
situation est réglée et je pense par
exemple la Chine alors quand on regarde
les courbes au niveau mondial on est à
peu près tous dans les mêmes même
situation que c'était un pays qui est la
Chine vous l'avez dit la Chine pour une
raison assez simple on l'a déjà dit mais
on va le répéter le pays a fait le choix
d'une stratégie zéro covid drastique et
c'est avoir le sens de la litote que que
la qualifier comme ça avec des
confinements réguliers et donc n'a pas
confronté sa population au virus ça
c'est pas le seul pays avoir fait ce
choix là mais ce que ont réussi notre
pays la Chine n'a pas réussi à le faire
c'est à dire sa campagne vaccinale pour
accompagner la sortie en Chine le SHIELD
la Chine n'a pas réussi à vacciner
correctement les personnes les plus
fragiles et notamment les plus âgées
pour pour plein de raisons certaines
qu'on arrive à expliquer d'autres et
notamment une habitude dans la dans la
médecine traditionnelle chinoise où on
vaccine pas les les plus les personnes
les plus âgées parce qu'on a peur de on
a peur des effets secondaires pour eux
donc il a fallu lutter contre ça et ce
qui fait que l'ouverture du pays il y a
quelques semaines maintenant a déclenché
une vague épidémique de contamination
très importante donc à la fois chez les
plus jeunes mais qui ont contaminé les
plus âgés qui eux n'étaient pas été pas
protégés et qui a amené une vague de
mortalité très importante dont on a pas
les chiffres parce que le pays refuse de
communiquer changer plusieurs fois ces
modes ces modes de calcul mais on sait
au vu des images qu'on a sur les
hôpitaux au vu aussi des des nécrologies
qui ont été publiées dans la presse avec
les personnalités connues que cette
vague est pas négligeable et surtout
très très importante donc à part ce ce
pays là les autres pays c'était
confrontés au virus avaient bien négocié
leur campagne de vaccination et dans les
pays qui avaient pas eu accès au vaccin
il y avait pas eu de confinement en
général sont des pays plutôt pauvres
avec une une moyenne
assez assez bas c'est ce qui fait que
l'impact du virus sur les populations
étaient beaucoup moins dramatique que
dans les pays les pays riches les pays
du Nord ou il y a plus de personnes
âgées donc plus de personnes fragiles en
gros ceux qui sera mort du covid dans
ces pays-là sont morts d'autres choses
avant et donc ils ont pas été frappé par
par la maladie et donc la Chine rattrape
en quelque sorte ces pays on arrive à
une harmonisation où tout le monde est
sur un pied d'égalité avec on estime que
95% de la population mondiale selon les
sur les études a été contaminées par au
micron si on ajoute à ça le vaccination
on a quand même une un bouclier
immunitaire assez fort à la fois
individuel et collectif d'accord est-ce
que ça veut dire que parce que on sait
il faut être très prudent
vous les experts à qui vous allez
discuter est-ce qu'ils ont dit on aura
la réponse d'ici deux mois sur la fin la
pandémie c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure il y a plusieurs temps de
il y a plusieurs faim en fait
la fin définitive on ne saura que dans
quelques années on verra si le covid
continue à tuer et par ailleurs il y a
plein de conséquences à long terme du
covid les covidon les infections
vasculaires et plein de points
d'interrogation sur lesquels on n'a pas
encore des réponses le covid a pas de
café fini d'impacter nos vies ça c'est
ça c'est sûr par contre
on a terminé avec la phase aiguë ça
c'est ça c'est une certitude maintenant
on va voir comment est-ce que vont ce
que je disais tout à l'heure va comment
va se dessiner cette géographie des
virus hivernaux avec ce nouveau virus
qui est quand même extrêmement
contagieux qui le sarcope 2 et qui dans
certains cas peut être peut être très
dangereux
mais les gens à qui on a l'habitude de
parler à qui on a parlé toutes les
semaines voire tous les jours pendant
plusieurs mois son passé à une nouvelle
phase et il y a plus la même inquiétude
et encore une fois moi quand j'appelle
les des médecins des personnels en
réanimation qui dans nos travail c'est
d'entuber qui ont fait face à une
pression très forte pendant le pendant
les premières vagues ce qui me disent
mot pour moi ce qui aujourd'hui leur
fait peur c'est pas ça Coffe 2 c'est
même pas la grippe ou ou la brocoli
c'est l'organisation de l'hôpital qui a
un certain nombre de problèmes l'absence
de le manque de personnel et notamment
de personnes infirmier un problème
structuel qui fait qu'on a travers ce
qu'on a eu du mal à affronter cette
triple épidémie qui était peut-être
exceptionnel surtout pour la banque
élite mais qui était surtout prévisible
parce qu'on savait que le covid circuit
est toujours on savait qu'il y avait
cette question sur des virus qui ont pas
circulé pendant deux ans et donc la
possibilité qui est qui est plus de cas
et pour autant on a quand même
totalement subi des urgences qui ont été
obligées de fermer je répète pas ce
qu'on a pu raconter à la fois sur ce
plateau et dans le journal pendant
plusieurs semaines mais le problème là
et pas comme et pas comparable avec
celui de mars 2020 ou le virus sort de
Chine et nouveau et déroule et donc on
n'a pas de solution on est démuni on est
obligé de sortir l'armad atomique et qui
est celle du confinement là on était
dans quelque chose de prévisible on n'a
pas réussi à y faire face
effectivement on a une question de
valpazu qui nous dit mais les Chinois
voyagent et peuvent faire revenir le
virus alors j'avais Cyril van Elberg
quand j'avais du service
aucun impact bah oui parce que le virus
circule largement alors maintenant on
est à moins de 5 ans par jour donc il
circulait beaucoup moins mais ce qui
faut regarder c'est les sous du virus
qui circulent en Chine pour le coup il y
a quand même un réseau de surveillance
au niveau mondial qui a été mise en
place de surveillance génomique assez
efficace et il y a beaucoup de
scientifiques qui séquence une part des
tests PCR donc quand on met son
coton-tige dans le nez on va regarder
s'il y a si un virus dedans et une
partie de ces tests sont analysées plus
profondément pour savoir si le test est
positif quelle souche du virus c'est
quelle est sa particularité génétique et
donc cette surveillance pour le moment
ne montre pas qu'en Chine émergence d'un
nouveau variant donc le virus qui
circule actuellement en Chine c'est les
mêmes que ceux qui ont circulé cet hiver
là donc si
aucun voyage en étant malade et en
porteur du virus et qui passerait entre
les mailles des tests PCR et qui
contaminent déjà en France il y a pas de
raison que cette condamnation soit plus
grave des qu'une des 4 5 4500
contaminations quotidienne qu'on peut
avoir actuellement parce que c'est une
source qui est comparable qui devrait
pas des jouer le bouclier immunitaire à
la fois individuel et collectif et le la
bonne nouvelle c'est que à la fois on
aurait pu craindre donc un nouveau
variant en Chine mais c'est que partout
dans le monde le réseau tu reviens sur
le moment ne met pas au jour de variant
particulièrement inquiétant il y a un
certain nombre de variants nouveaux qui
circulent je pense au
xbb 1.5 j'ai un doute sur le nom à
l'instant qui circule aux États-Unis
depuis
quelques semaines maintenant qui a eu
une augmentation assez fulgurante c'est
bien ça le titre c'est ça bravo et il y
a le cul
qqx un point je crois au Royaume-Uni
enfin bref et la même manière qui a
amené une hausse très importante des des
cas au début mais une autre
proportionnelle par rapport aux autres
variants leur
il semblerait pas que si jamais devait
arriver en France il modifierait le
paysage le paysage
épidémique peut-être qu'il pourrait
donner lieu à un robot mais ce robot
n'aurait pas être particulièrement haut
il y a pas d'éléments en tout cas de le
penser que ce soit au vu des ce qui se
passe actuellement dans ces pays-là et
puis au vu aussi des analyses génomiques
on a pu faire sur ces virus alors est-ce
qu'il nous reste encore des choses à
prendre sur ce covid je vois valpatite
qui nous pose une question mais il y a
les covidons ceux qui laissent des
traces sur les poumons les covidons
d'ailleurs vous pouvez retrouver un
article dans le journal du jour une
amélioration fréquente au bout d'un
moment exactement la première chose sur
le covidon aussi énormément de choses à
apprendre et ce que je disais le il y a
plusieurs fins dans l'épidémie le covid
n'a pas fini de marquer nos vies et il y
a encore des milliers de personnes qui
vont mourir de la maladie et il faut le
dire comme ça c'est pour ça que
continuer à se protéger continuer à
vacciner à se vacciner à vacciner le
plus fragile ça reste essentiel parce
que c'est c'est des gens qu'on peut
mauvais c'est en fait c'est simplement
on a les outils pour protéger certaines
personnes donc autant les utiliser et ne
pas le faire enfin ne pas le faire ne
pose un certain nombre de questions donc
la question des donc des personnes
fragiles à protéger et aussi la personne
des covidons qui est très intéressante
il y a une étude israélienne là qui est
sorti il y a quelques semaines faites
sur plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes à partir des données de la
sécurité sociale israélienne qui montre
que
une personne qui s'ouvre du covidon dans
la plupart de cas je sais plus les
pourcentages en tête je crois que c'est
au delà de 90% au bout d'un an c'est 50%
six mois et 90 je crois un an et
totalement remise donc il reste quand
même des gens qui sont malades et le
virus a circulé très largement donc même
si on parle de pourcentage très faible
et donc 1% de de cas graves de
complications vasculaire 1% sur les
millions de personnes qu'on a eu on va
dire qu'il y a 40 millions de personnes
c'est ce qu'on estime contaminés par vos
micro en France en pourtant ça fait
quand même plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes et donc c'est des
choses qui vont devoir être pris en
charge il va falloir répondre à ça le
covidence est
un mot générique pour plein de choses
qu'on comprend pas c'est c'est
pathologique qui dure mais ce qui est
vraiment intéressant avec ce virus et
que ça a mis au jour un phénomène qui
est sans doute présent dans l'ensemble
des infections c'est à dire que quand on
est malade il y a des gens qui
s'embêtent et d'autres qui mettent
beaucoup plus de temps et il y en a pour
qu'il y aura des complications et comme
là on a eu énormément de malades avec un
même virus on a eu un effet de loupe
mais cet effet de loupe en fait il va
peut-être nous permettre de comprendre
ces infections long terme et et il y a
tout un intérêt à continuer à focaliser
nos recherches là-dessus et surtout à
pas mépriser les gens qui qui sont
malades dont on ne comprend pas la cause
parce que le mal existe et si elle le
comprendre pour soigner les covidons
mais aussi les les infections long terme
pour d'autres maladies très bien
effectivement vous pouvez retrouver cet
article de poinfrehour sur justement le
covid long et qui parle aussi du
chikungunya par exemple
par Benjamin de la vidéo voilà qui dit
qui donne la même chose une dernière
question quand même sur une autre un
autre mystère de ce covid c'est son
origine bien évidemment est-ce que trois
ans après l'apparition de cette maladie
on en sait plus non non c'est pas
beaucoup plus il y a des il y a des
points de certitudes on les répète à
chaque fois les points de certitude
c'est
le départ de la pandémie on est aux
alentours de décembre 2019 le lieu donc
on est dans la vidéo one avec sans doute
un départ de un foyer au niveau du
marché
et ensuite les autres certitudes
malheureusement elle nous plonge bien
plus loin géographiquement et dans le
temps donc c'est des virus retrouver des
chez des chauves-souris à 2000 km de là
de là au nord du Laos qui sont très
proches et éthiquement du du saskov 2
mais qui
ne semble pas être l'ancêtre direct même
si on en sait on en sait on n'en sait
rien et à qui il manque en tout cas une
caractéristique essentielle qui fait du
sascope 2 aussi contagieux par rapport
d'aérosols et donc il faut boucher les
trous entre eux entre ces deux ces deux
c'est deux éléments et donc il y a plein
d'hypothèses qui existent une virus qui
pourrait circuler à bas bruit et qui
récupère cette particularité génétique
qui lui permet d'être hyper contagieux
aux alentours de Novembre Décembre 2019
c'est possible un virus qui ont été
conservé dans un laboratoire parce que
dangereux et contaminé par une
manipulation c'est possible aussi et
même pourquoi pas un virus manipulé
parce qu'on sait que c'est des choses
qui ont pu être fait au niveau de
l'Institut de virologie de Yohan sur
d'autres virus on a aucune preuve sur
les sascoves bien entendu
mais et pour ça il faut avoir un certain
nombre de réponses et enfin pour avoir
des réponses il faut avoir ça tombe
d'éléments qui notamment on en revient à
la génétique les analyses génétiques du
paysage viral au début de la pandémie
euh quand les gens il y a eu pas mal de
cas de de grippe Awan en novembre il y a
eu des tests PCR on aimerait pouvoir
séquencer ces tests on aimerait savoir
quels sont les virus sont conservés dans
les dans les laboratoires et puis on
aimerait aussi qui est beaucoup plus de
travail sur le terrain aux alentours de
de ces fameux plateau au sud de la Chine
au nord de la hausse et essayer de
trouver des virus encore plus proche de
pour pouvoir remonter cette histoire
donc le fait que là la Chine fait pas
preuve d'une transparence absolue mais
je tiens à dire que ça veut pas dire que
il y a une respirer peut aussi
considérer qu'elle en a dit suffisamment
parce qu'elle n'avait rien d'autre à
dire et refusé d'en venir plus et la
manière que elle peut aussi avoir envie
cacher des des façons dont on conservait
les animaux et notamment les civettes
qui ont été le foyer de départ du
saskovin la pandémie de 2000 2003
avec des mesures sanitaires qui avaient
pas forcément été prises donc il y a
plein de raisons qui fait que on n'est
pas dans la transparence absolue et
c'est quand même assez problématique
merci beaucoup Vincent mais en tout cas
d'avoir avec nous pour en parler merci à
vous les internautes du Figaro nous
avoir suivi la suite du programme c'est
à 17h avec le buzz TV la question du
jour à 17h30 on demandera si Louis de
Funès est le plus grand acteur comique
français je vous donne rendez-vous à
17h30 pour cela puis 18h point de vue
20h le club idées et enfin 22h une
émission avec Hugo Becker Figaro la nuit
deux heures dans Paris avec Hugo Becker
c'est retrouver à partir de 22h moi je
vous dis à bientôt sur le Figaro